this is jonathan ferguson the keeper of
firearms and artillery at the royal
armies museum in the uk which houses a
collection of thousands of iconic
weapons from throughout history and on
this episode we've nearly broken poor
jonathan with some of the most cursed
customizations that call of duty
vanguard's multiplayer has to offer god
i think this is a garand what have they
done to you i can hear john cancious
garand revolving in his grave probably
more efficiently than this drum mag
revolves
if you want to see more of jonathan's
take on the weapons of call of duty
we've got you covered with videos on
black ops cold war world war ii and
2019's modern warfare and if there are
any other games guns and mechanics do
you guys want to see jonathan break down
let us know in the comment section below
be sure to subscribe for more videos
like this one and if you'd like to help
out the royal armies museum and continue
to support jonathan's work check out the
links in the description of this video
right over to jonathan
okay i think we're off to a strong start
because although this is a prototype
russian
assault rifle that never saw service
this is the tsudayev as44 despite that
it looks pretty good and i'm kind of a
sort of a fan of having things that
really existed
well modelled well textured in a game
that has a fantastic setting anyway now
there's something uh not right with the
front end of this the heat shield from
memory is longer with more holes and the
finned barrel again i don't remember
seeing a photo of an as44 with a thinned
barrel so i suspect this has been
modified in game or they've got it wrong
but i suspect it's a modification
all right we'll pause there there's just
going to be a lot of pained wintering
going on i think in this review wow
where to start so this is clearly
somewhere in the past life a browning
bar m1918 a2 you can tell from the
magazine guides even if all the other
features have been altered by some
sadistic maniac the egyptian slash east
german slash
polish-esque ak wire folding buttstock
makes me cry a little inside the broom
handle vertical foregrip i can i can
latch on to as something that people
really did improvise in the field that's
perhaps plausible the whole front end is
just kind of wacky looking it looks like
thin barrels are a standard option for
the weapons in this game i mean needless
to say in real life you can't just pull
a barrel and replace it with a thinned
barrel and any cooling benefit it gave
you would be
minimal which is why they went away
as a thing they were deleted because it
was cheaper to make and quicker to make
a gun and they really didn't do that
much
for dissipating heat not nothing but not
much
and pause again there because we have
one of these heinous optical sights
i'm not sure what it looks like it's
tiny i mean we can barely make optical
sights as with a field of view like this
now so we certainly didn't have them in
the 1940s and while i'm staring at it at
least of this guns problems but the
carrying handle is anachronistic
browning a 1918 a2 did not have the
carrying handle in the second world war
[Music]
again where to start so buttstock what's
going on there don't know what that's
supposed to be looks like it might be
inspired by the uzi buttstock which
which folds under the gun this clearly
doesn't do that looks like it hinges to
the side okay maybe for transporting the
gun but with this drum magazine on there
that's not going to work the the
buttstock's going to hit the mag
speaking of the drum magazine
what
so we do have pump action
shotguns now that will feed from a box
or a drum magazine inserted under the
action like a rifle and it makes the the
tube magazine where the pump grip is
redundant so that's a real
thing definitely not a real thing in the
1940s so that sticks out like a sore
thumb we've got a ludicrously huge
foregrip attached to the pump grip which
you'd normally just grab and pump so
don't have a huge problem with wooden
foregrips on things they bodged them
onto all sorts of guns that that i can
get my head around what you couldn't do
is turn an 1897 into a mag fed a
conventional mag fed
gun so this isn't utterly heinous but
the i think the drum and the stock push
it over the edge for me
insta paws there so for some reason i'm
fixating on the black strip on the grip
having seen that on another gun and it
looks for all the world like that's grip
tape now the idea of putting skateboard
tape or a specialist firearms version of
it on the grip of your firearm to make
it less slippery is definitively a 21st
century phenomenon that may be the least
of our problems so what have we got here
well let's grab a real one so leaving
aside the drum magazine what we sort of
got here
is the luger carbine obvious difference
is the barrel is
a lot shorter a good couple of inches
shorter in the game otherwise we've got
a thompson cuts compensator on the end
of the barrel i mean this this has the
muzzle design of the standard luger or
the artillery luger rather than this
just tapered barrel it has a swollen tip
you can't just
stick a cuts on the end of that that
should be
over that portion of the barrel and
pinned on you know it's just magically
stuck to the end and then we turn to the
drum magazine now this is in 765 luger
so won't fit the drum this was
originally designed for for the luger
for the nine millimeter po8 um for use
with the the long barrelled version and
was then adapted for use on the bergmann
mp18 submachine gun the magazine in the
game looks basically nothing like it
it's like they saw it once and i've just
made their own
mission ready oh wow paul's there oh wow
canted
offset not even iron sights so this this
1940s handgun has not one but two
optical sights on it a telescopic style
one that looks vaguely like it might
exist in the 1940s albeit with a yellow
illuminated reticle that didn't exist
yet and then canted and offset like a
modern like a modern rifle with a red
dot sight for close quarters that's what
this has er the world's tiniest 1940s
reflector gun sight mounted on the side
of the site mount
all right
oh god okay this confused me initially
someone is um someone's playing games
with me i looked at the barrel and
thought is this and the mag and the drum
type magazine thought is this an mg15 no
the back end looks like a 42. it is in
fact an mg42 that somebody has somehow
replaced the whole barrel assembly and
half the receiver effectively with a an
mg34 style barrel and they have removed
the buttstock now it's been a while
since i took an mg42 apart but i think
when you do that you lose your recoil
spring so i don't think that's possible
and it's certainly not desirable because
how are you going to shoot it without a
butt stock but clearly that will confer
some benefit in the game uh i'm not even
going to ask what
again barely recognizable as a mosin
rifle m1891 carbine maybe or even cut
down more than that it's very short a
really weird bit of iron shelving
monopod but of course i don't know we're
in multiplayer here i have to remember
we're in multiplayer but it's just
ridiculous
so we've got a modification to box
magazine feed which i don't think
would well i'm i'm fairly certain
wouldn't work because this box magazine
is inserted into the magazine housing
therefore the box magazine is narrower
than the actual magazine in the gun i
don't think the rounds would even fit
it's got an enormous what looks like
magazine catch that's attached to the
magazine not to the magazine well
effectively
so even if that would work you're gonna
hit it by accident have your magazine
fall out we've then got weird like 1980s
ford escort upholstery as a sort of grip
zone on the semi-pistol grip on this
thing and then i don't know what that is
on the base of that and a really a
really weird modern looking monte carlo
esque semi-pistol grip butt stock that
didn't exist
okay so this is not not quite as wacky
as it looks so this is actually
based upon the mp41 which is
a weird reversion of the mp3840 design
to the old style bergmann rifle style
wooden stock so this did happen in 1941
these were actually produced and issued
alongside the mp38 and the mp40 so
seeing this in the game
absolutely fine good way to change
things up a little bit it's got quite a
different aesthetic but the way this has
been modified so cheek riser like it's
like a modern sniper rifle i don't think
those even existed for sniper rifles in
the 40s i'm pretty sure of that
that's a bit mad we've got a weirdly out
of scale thompson 1921 1928 foregrip
bodged onto the bottom of this wooden
stock
like it's the wrong size there's no
visible means of attaching it i guess
they could have put a bolt up through no
i mean if you look at the bottom of this
thing this is all part of the
receiver of the weapon it's not wood you
can't easily you'd have to drill drill
and tap the metal again i'm overthinking
this one
hostile recon in the air spies in the
sky recon sweep in the sector
double kill
right well this is a version of the
charlton rifle this is the electrolux
made version of it in australia but the
design was new zealand and that's
reflected in the there's a made-up name
for this this has been mercifully left
mostly as it is in real life i spoke a
little too soon we have some grip tape
on this as well i don't know whose idea
it was to to put 21st century grip tape
on 1940s guns but there we are lots of
lovely detail on this model we can see
the massive great gas cylinder on the
side of this thing that turns it from a
bolt action
into a
an automatic rifle so a great job with
the gun it's the modifications that
players can
do to it and if you do this it's your
own fault
fight back
pause there hold the phone
30 round magazine capacity that is very
clearly the smelly 10-round magazine
that is actually on the charlton rifles
how that's three times the size i don't
know quantum singularity in the bottom
of the magazine box or something
personally i would have upped the damage
or something and kept the capacity
realistic
yeah
even though i've seen this one before it
still makes me twitch right so let's
break this down shall we we have here
what happens when you put all your sten
guns in the dryer this is what comes out
so we have a mark ii sten front uh sort
of barrel and definitely the hand guard
with the holes in it that's mark ii sten
then we have a mark one sten
substantially with its wooden front
furniture thing and vertical folding
foregrip but covered in paint and then
we have a mark 5 esque butt stock
assembly on the back of it so we have a
mash up of three different marks of sten
with an a historical suppressor and a
historical reflex sight and a historical
pistol grip that i don't recognize and a
slightly silly paint scheme so a real
real mash-up now what i what i've as i
often do i grabbed something from the
collection and i wondered which mark of
sten to grab all of them no
instead i thought i'd show you what
the game could have done this is one of
the mark iv experimental stems
so it has a suppressor on it much bigger
you'll notice a suppressor of that small
volume wouldn't be very efficient and
then it has
an unusual shaped pistol grip so that's
a box tick with an even more unusual
trigger guard and
a weird stock now this was for
paratroopers in theory so you pull this
catch you rotate
and then you
lock it into place and you have this you
can even use it as a foregrip super
compact
very cool looking
but it actually existed in the middle of
the war period
[Music]
all right paul's out of the gate with
whatever this is
god i think this is a garand what have
they done to you
yeah definitely a garand action some
bizarre very
1990s to 2000s looking sporting
stock ludicrous tank style or maybe boys
esque not really muzzle break on the end
there guess that would help with the
recoil of the cartridge it would did
they have them then no and we've got an
optical sight mounted over in front of
the action so at least we're not
blocking anything from functioning there
now we did have garands with optical
sights mounted on them but not in the
second world war the m1c the m1d were as
far as i know they may have been
developed by 1945 but they were not
issued and we have a
drum magazine because of course we do i
can hear john cantius garand revolving
in his grave probably more efficiently
than this drum mag revolves
what
what
what
what just happened i didn't notice it
the first time but we shoot this this
abomination dry and there's there's the
iconic ping we can hear the ping but if
you look at the action nothing comes out
except maybe the last case something's
gone wrong here and an m1 ping without
the clip very confusing
oh
i'm actually speechless at this thing
let's try from the front shall we we've
got a vaguely period looking muzzle
break not really that much recoil on on
a sturmgiver which is clearly what this
this was before it was butchered we've
got a delightful black and gold colour
scheme which i don't hate actually i
think that's the thing i hate least
about this we've got a drum magazine
because why not
it's not sure what's going on with the
sights but i'm not going to like it i'm
pretty sure and then more grip tape more
gold and then for some reason we've got
a sort of h and k
end cap for an mp5 or something
transported back through a wormhole to
the stoma bear so we've got no butt
stock just like a blanked off cat at
least we've got that at least the recoil
spring isn't free to fly out the back of
the gun the gun would actually
work maybe if there's enough
room there not entirely sure and frankly
i'm slightly losing the will to live
wow
wow
wow
what can i say about this thing
it looks like somebody took a
welding torch cutting torch sorry uh to
a thompson so we've got uh ostensibly a
1920-28
type receiver with the cuts for the drum
mag although the lower is m1 we've got a
skeletal
machined out grip which you'll see
occasionally these days more so in games
in real life there's nothing like that
at this time except for the sten had a i
believe experimental only sheet metal
folded welded
skeletal pistol grip with a back plate
so you didn't have to have a stock on it
four paratroopers so that was real that
did exist but didn't look like this and
it wasn't on a thompson yeah
the barrel's been cut right
back it's probably an inch and a half
long that's not gonna do your ballistics
any favors i can't quite work out what's
going on with the foregrip but holding
this thing would be difficult and
uncomfortable and you'd probably shoot
your fingers off let's see it in action
never seen anyone do a tactical reload
with a hundred round thompson mag before
having handled one and fired a 1921
thompson with that drum fitted let me
tell you simply replacing the mag of
taking the magazine off and putting it
on is difficult holding two of these
gigantic things in one hand
and like doing a retention reload with
them no if you were lucky enough to have
more than one of these mags i don't know
what you do um but you wouldn't be able
to do that
losing objective baker
mission ready
all right uh we've had the the
volkswagen
on the series before and you may recall
that it is meant to be an extremely
simple
semi-automatic rifle for the use of
reserve like last-ditch troops
so what you don't want to be doing is
pimping it like it's your ride with
ludicrous drum magazines foregrips
optical sights weird bird charms and or
anything else that's been applied to
this unfortunate beast yeah so this this
thing has another issue which is a
common one in computer game
representations of the volkswagen which
is it comes from the name
people assume it's people's assault
rifle and therefore it's automatic it
wasn't it was self-loading only what it
actually is is volksdam as in the german
home guard gover rifle so i think it's a
simple misunderstanding of of the name
so it should not be firing automatically
and it definitely shouldn't be festooned
with nonsense right just for our our
collective sanity i feel like i need to
to hold this and tell it that
everything's gonna be okay having seen
that version this is a proper sgg44
unmolested but it does have an actual
second world war optical sight on it
that was actually designed to be used on
this rifle now in the event very few
actually made it out of the factory i'm
not sure they were ever officially
issued there are test
trials photos of them being used out in
the field but at least it existed when
whenever we see i see one of these
anachronistic optical sites i think of
this because it's the closest thing
we've got to something
like that and it is in the game so they
have they have represented it i believe
the idea was to have one in each
grouper each squad
with this site so they could function as
a designated marksman albeit with a
reduced power cartridge so if you want a
modernized world war two rifle
this should be it
[Music]
what i want to do now is thank all of
you who actually followed me over to the
royal armouries youtube channel we
really appreciate how many of you have
done that because it's let us
get this
we have got
100 000 subscribers we've actually got
144 000 subscribers in no small part
thanks to you guys so thank you very
much indeed if you haven't checked out
our channel over at the royal armouries
please do so and as always we've got
links in the description to
for donations and our membership scheme
thanks again guys see you next time
[Music]
you